sup guys welcome to megabit it's monday
i'm here with Maxwell McGee I'm yolks
replaying Cassidy bloodlines today and
well this is a game made by Konami came
out in 1994 for the Sega Genesis it's
the only Castlevania game on the Sega
Genesis which is really quite a shame
yeah so Elizabeth Bartley Lizabeth
bought the legendary vampire that we've
all heard of uh you know she's causing
some [ __ ] Dracula's castle that kind of
thing yeah I'm gonna start off with Eric
look hard it was a card with the AL card
spear not to confuse you the alucard
sphere which might be a thing notice his
hair is green or like this blue color
but then oh wait there's Jack this
castle oh there it is oh man and his
blue hair is suddenly blonde I think was
also blonde in the quick intro it was
well yeah it was a last-minute thing
they were like American audiences love
green hair make his hair green ok if we
make his hair blonde people think he's a
lady and then like so his fears got
pretty reach you can view this little
spinny animation to do light attacks on
enemies oh it's so good he's also got a
charge jump it's got some mario bros to
jump yeah according to wikipedia i'll do
it the legendary vampire elizabeth
barley Dracula's nice and i doing that
boy someone suddenly appears in the 20th
century plotting a sacrificial war in
order to bring her uncle back to life
she orchestrates the beginning of world
war one what do you know because why not
Quincy Morris's son John and his best
pal Eric mcard vowed to take up the
fight against evil together they managed
to prevent Dracula's full Reds off
spoilers they prevent dragons full
resurrection sorry folks they do in fact
prevent he does not come back poor
Elizabeth Lizzie at a collar as
Dracula's nieces friends collar
got a good got a good jumping
competition having here this guy see who
can jump higher all oh he's a jiggling
watch out he's convinced the jiggling ok
now it's cool it's cool weapons you
managed to knock the acts out it up no
he lost oh just doing the foot he's a
kicker we got a kicker you got ya I got
it I got on the ropes we I'm so done
he's so done victory jump into the
magical work all ok you got this time no
one more there we go belmont's are known
the other you know the normal cast is
known for wearing such miniskirts that's
true they gotta have that free range of
motion when they're climbing all those
stairs and jumping around and whipping
dudes any junk unrestricted it's like a
tommy hilfiger like one of their sub
branch goofy junk unrestricted there's
just a bunch of black and white images
of dudes just hanging out with I guess
their junk unobstructed unobstructed how
do those things go through that building
I had a Medusa heads and what you do is
not with this stream needs it specific
there the minecarts of Castlevania oh
whoa oh take that classic art I have no
respect for you that's right brown work
so good Genesis sound effects so good
wow this turkey is not gonna be here I
thought you're talking about the bad guy
I'll have to take this [ __ ] turn hey
hey we're all our folks gap ah damn it
damn it I can't wait until someone
offers me ten dollars for megabit it's
coming one of those days just gonna cash
it in do the show that dudes like well
ah I just won't kill myself you just
sound like roll through it uh-oh whoa
Eric hey I'm plugging all of the
equipment in the studio Oh commanded by
air megawatts up to ten dollars of icons
offering 25 oh we just Eric we just got
word Viacom they want it they got 25 for
you really just unplug the whole
freaking thing did you look at this guy
oh look at this dude freakin wait a
minute t3h HH and the chat says this guy
is seriously chiseled do mom nailed it
you just won the chat nice one of us got
up no no no that's where I'd anteater
this is what happens huh this is what
happens oh yeah I mean when oh you know
what I just walked off the stairs max
now might be a great time now might be a
good time to make a switch 54 MP bird
bird and bee birth and we must indeed
and filling up
jus is a letter in Barranca very hurt
and Bieber between feeders and filling
up to a subpoena it's this one this one
don't go immediately immediately what
the hell Avril time I went to wardrobe
attack of the jump like I did last time
and he came backwards on I've gotten hit
like twice okay then did you see that
[ __ ] Medusa head oh my god bridge and
then it'll be everything will be good
look at the man just when you're making
this jump just look at the back Oh God
so many deaths more than I already do Oh
design messed up
no you can't just do that I do said this
is the insanity that was just level
eight Wow cool well thanks for watching
me fail admirably once again admirable
you always do it admirably huh thank you
thank you once again you guys for
watching mega [ __ ] city folks just own
bed folks just don't get it thanks for
watching everybody take care